margot robbie's first look as barbie
will have you saying it's fantastic
[Music]
you know the song and now a movie on
tuesday warner brothers gave fans their
first sneak peek at the actress as the
iconic doll in the live action film
called
what else
barbie that's a 31 year old i tonya star
sitting in a hot pink convertible
wearing a blue and white striped top
with coordinating accessories
expect the unexpected it's not going to
be whatever you're thinking it's not
it's not that the film is scheduled to
hit theaters july 21 2023 and margot who
also serves as a producer isn't the only
a-lister set to appear in the flick i
mean it's crazy ryan gosling is expected
to portray barbie's boyfriend ken
it's the happiest time in my life simulu
will ferrell america ferreira alexandra
ship michael sarah issa rae and kate
mckinnon have all signed on as well
i'm just so happy to be a part of it the
movie which is currently being filmed in
the uk is directed by greta gerwig who
also co-wrote the script and when e.t
chatted with greta back in 2020 she
opened up about the gig
it's early days i don't want to jinx
anything because you never know because
it's such a long process i mean i have a
feeling that whatever we turn in as the
script people are going to be like are
you insane you can't make this
which is always i think a good sign
but the film has been on a bit of a
journey as it was originally slated to
be an amy schumer project
you know there was an announcement that
i might star in this movie as uh playing
i won't say the name of it but it rhymes
with shmarby so a bunch of times
throughout my career people have been
like you're too fat or just i've been
you know bullied and what's cool
is um from being in the public eye for
this long is people you first of all you
build up um
a thicker skin from it and then you're
like wait a minute no
i
i look in the mirror and i know who i am
and i feel beautiful and i feel strong
amy was originally cast to play barbie
in 2016 before backing out just four
months later citing scheduling conflicts
but last month the comedian told the
hollywood reporter that creative
differences led to her departure
quote they definitely didn't want to do
it the way i wanted to do it the only
way i was interested in doing it
the way she wanted to do it showing
barbie getting kicked out of barbie land
for not being perfect enough amy also
said that her barbie was written as an
ambitious inventor but sony the original
studio behind the film reportedly wanted
that invention to be a high heel shoe
made out of jell-o a decision amy was
not on board with
it was later rumored that anne hathaway
was set to take over the role but the
project was scrapped and started fresh
over at warner brothers and for now plot
details are being kept under wraps
i can only tease that i'm so excited
it's going to be incredible greta gerwig
obviously is an amazing
writer and director and margot is
flawless fabulous
[Music]